merci la parole est à madame geneviève
lévy madame la présidente niger
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre des affaires sociales de la
santé des droits des femmes et j'y
associe mon collègue philippe vitel
madame la ministre
samedi dernier aux urgences de l'hôpital
sainte musse dans ma circonscription à
toulon deux personnels de santé ont été
agressé une infirmière a été prise à
partie par les proches d'une patiente et
un brancardier a été battu littéralement
piétinés par une quinzaine d'hommes
déchaîné qui ont envahi l'espace
hospitalier ce n'est pas un fait divers
c'est une manifestation de défi aux
institutions au même titre que les
violences intervenues dans les
commissariats où les écoles à l'hôpital
le mal-être quotidiens gagnés les
personnels de santé
devant la montée d'apt particulièrement
odieux bafouant les valeurs de la
république
trois des agresseurs enchères en certes
écopé d'une peine de prison ferme ou
avec sursis
lors d'une comparution immédiate mais
les stigmates au sein des services des
agences tools des urgences toulonnais
sont profonds selon l'observatoire
national dès violences en milieu de
santé les chiffres augmentent chaque
année faisant 21 mille victimes dont 78
% de professionnels de santé à l'été
vous aviez annoncé un grand plan de
prévention en vous appuyant sur les
agences régionales de santé
mais force est de constater que les
annonces n'ont pas été suivies d'effet
et que les hôpitaux sont désormais la
cible de provocation anti républicaine
quand allez-vous donner aux
professionnels de santé les moyens
humains matériels et financiers
d'assurer leur sécurité
madame la ministre l'hôpital ne doit pas
être une zone de non droit l'hôpital ne
doit pas être le laisser pour compte de
la république
qu'attendez vous pour protéger nos
personnels de santé et pour qu'il ne
travaille plus la peur au ventre
merci la parole est établi
am la ministre des affaires sociales de
la santé et des droits des femmes
merci madame la présidente madame la
députée geneviève lévy les agressions
dans les hôpitaux comme dans tous les
lieux publics d'ailleurs ces agressions
sont inacceptables et intolérables et
vous l'avez dit
les agressions contre des professionnels
de santé qui travaillent pour sauver des
vies ces agressions se sont des
agressions contre la république et
contre le service public c'est pour cela
que au mois de septembre 2013 un plan a
été mise en place et qui d'ailleurs a
donné des résultats dans la situation
que vous évoquez nous avons pris un
ensemble de mesures la première a
consisté à permettre aux hôpitaux
d'accéder à un fonds interministériel de
prévention de la délicate de la
délinquance pour s'équiper en matière de
vidéoprotection ce fonds existent les
hôpitaux peuvent y avoir recours la
deuxième mesure que nous avons prises en
relation avec les agences régionales de
santé
c'est la signature d'un protocole
national entre le ministère de la santé
et le ministère de l'intérieur des
conventions locales ont été signés qui
permettent aux établissements d'avoir
dans leurs murs un correspondant local
police ou gendarmerie et à l'hôpital
sainte musse c'est ce qu'il y avait il y
avait un correspondant au sein de
l'établissement
ce qui a permis une arrivée très rapide
de la police et comme vous l'avez dit
l'agression est intervenue samedi
dernier madame la députée et trois
agresseurs ont d'ores et déjà été
condamné en comparution immédiate à des
peines de quatre et deux mois de prison
ferme vous le voyez madame la députée
nous agissons avec beaucoup de fermeté
et nous n'acceptons pas les violences
contre les professionnels de santé et
c'est tous ensemble que nous devrions
lutter à cet effet merci la parole